hello everyone I'm Walter Binet VI kän
this is top five today we were turn to
counting down the best and worst of our
favourite actors the legend who just
earned his seventh Oscar nomination does
enzo washington even have any bad
performances guess we're going to find
out so since we've had three best lifts
in a row i decided to go with denzel
zwarst first however this is another
case where an actor of his caliber
doesn't really have any bad performances
Denzel has been acting in TV and film
since the late 70s and has become one of
the most respected people in his field
his range is incredibly wide as he often
showcases his talent in massively
different characters I really had to dig
into his filmography to find anything
subpar and even then he's worth is
better than most actors better he's held
to a high standard and should be with
the amazing work he's put out let's dive
in here of the top 5 worst Denzel
Washington performances number 5 Rueben
James in for Queen and country
this one week came out in 1988 and had
Washington playing a Brit with a pretty
darn good English accent Rueben James is
a paratrooper who is discharged from the
British military and decides to go back
to the London inner-city neighborhood he
grew up in however once there he has met
with an unwelcoming set of circumstances
that starts pushing him down a path he
does not want to go down some paths
friends are now enemies as a
neighborhood and his country seemed to
have turned against them Denzel is
actually not bad in this the character
is pretty dull which makes her a few
boring scenes but all in all he's pretty
decent he's just not on the mega high
level we all know him best for while we
see early signs of badass characters he
would play years down the road Rueben
James comes up short on that in a
Korriban so look of--my might
pakkaaa Rizla that's all I got me mate
the film itself has its moments but just
drags for way too long
if you're a huge Denzel fan you'll
probably get something out of foreign
country but he's had a career full of
amazing performances and I don't see
much of a reason to dwell on this
mediocre one onto number four lieutenant
Parker Barnes in virtuosity got to admit
while this isn't really a good movie and
I wondered the whole time why he agreed
to be in this it can't be pretty
entertaining after murdering the man who
killed his wife and daughter Parker
Barnes is thrown in prison years later
he is recruited to test out a new
virtual reality program where he
attempts to capture the
computer-generated villain named Sid
six-point-seven Sid had been modelled on
hundreds of mass murdering criminals and
with help he is able to escape into the
real world
the police then cut a deal with Barnes
to catch the insane being before he
kills more people before I get to Denzel
Russell Crowe is not to miss in it's
amazing
he has just off the wall crazy and
that's a very least he's amusing enough
to check out this weird little movie in
a guilty pleasure kind of way it's sort
of like demolition man but not as
interesting or memorable my god he's
evolving into what
[Music]
now
besides crow in Washington we have the
USC ten shamrock and Michael buffer in
this thing it's great Denzel is very out
of place in this strange kitschy sci-fi
film and once again he's not bad but he
has nothing to work with his character
has plenty of motivation behind him but
just comes off too Hollow for anyone to
connect with or have sympathy for he
does have some sick dreads Oh check out
virtuosity if you want some weird 90 sci
fi camp but otherwise it's a weaker role
for denzel number 3 napoleon stone in
heart condition washington apparently
fired his manager after he was made to
do this movie I can see why racist
policeman Jack Mooney had spent years
for Pesci writing bad habits and they
eventually result in a life-threatening
heart attack to save his life Mooney
needs a heart transplant and gets one
from black lawyer napoleon stone who had
been sleeping with Jack's ex-girlfriend
Cristal Napoleon died mysteriously the
same night as Muniz heart attack and has
returned as a ghost to push the cop
towards finding his killer while
generally annoying him in the process
this was the first movie released after
denzel's oscar-winning performance and
glory
not exactly a stellar follow-up there's
not much form to sink its teeth into
here but his chemistry with Bob Hoskins
can be entertaining at a few points
what's the favorite movie Rambo Rambo
Washington's character just comes off
too unlikable add that to Hoskins
character who's supposed to be
over-the-top and likable and you have a
movie that can be a little difficult to
sit through we all know Denzel was above
this he knew it too and there's a reason
he's very rarely done straight comedies
after this was released I deter you from
checking it out but hey Bob Hoskins
getting a makeover is something you'd
like to see maybe you'll be interested
in what heart condition has to offer if
not it's a definite skip number two
Xavier Quinn in the mighty quinn Denzel
Washington should never be boring it
takes a special movie to make him that
way based on the 1971 novel finding
Malby
the mighty quinn files Caribbean island
police chief Xavier Quinn as he
investigates the death of a rich
resident of the island all signs point
to his childhood
and Maui as the lead suspect but Quinn
has a tough time bringing himself to
accept that his old friend could do such
a thing
with corruption all around him the chief
must navigate through personal and
political problems to find the truth the
mighty Quinn is the dullest movie on
this list it's only an hour and 38
minutes but it felt like I spent the
entire day watching this thing it wasn't
very clear what was happening throughout
the film and that made it even more
difficult to get through
plus they have meteor man in this movie
he's not even using his powers what a
waste
Sindel himself doesn't seem as engaged
as he usually is and that's very rare
from him this character isn't exactly
compelling how do I go
[Music]
like a ripe mango they have a few songs
thrown in there and they actually can be
kind of catchy
[Music]
Oh what the hell was that Wow Wow
and the number one worst then Zell
Washington performance is Roger Porter
in Carbon Copy so this movie is how can
I put this
dated Walter Whitney is a successful
married businessman who finds out he has
a long-lost black son named Roger when
he shows up in person to meet Walter
Whitney's inner circle is appalled by
the fact that he had an interracial
relationship and even more so that he
has a grown son he's kicked out of his
home by his wife as he and Roger
struggled to find a steady place to live
and work this was Washington's feature
film debut so he's only gone up from
here the character he's playing just
doesn't fit the persona we all know him
for now but it was a start for him in
the movie business prior to this he only
appeared in a couple TV films hi Daddy
good morning whitey Isaiah hockey
carbon-copy definitely wouldn't be seen
as politically correct now but I'm
guessing that was sort of the point back
then I will say though it goes pretty
far in a few areas that would make a lot
of people uncomfortable in addition to
the heavy racial themes it also delves
into a few questionable sexual situation
seeing Denzel is this young of a man is
very interesting there's not much of a
hint at what he was to become but if you
are a big follower of his career maybe
check it out for curiosity's sake and
see where this acting powerhouse started
mom was great for saving things I mean
if a bird left some crumbs on a
windowsill she'd leave a man like she
expected the bird to come back or
something I mean it never entered her
mind that the bird had forgotten where
she lived now that that's out of the way
I'm looking forward to next week
denzel's Beth won't be easy to choose
but it's going to be fun diving into his
greatest work I want to hear what you
guys think do you have a least favorite
Denzel Washington performance and/or
movie leave a comment and let me know
make sure you check out all some comics
from yesterday
Heather Porter and Ayane are counting
down the top 10 episodes of the 90s
x-men animated series follow me on
Twitter and awesome underscore Walter to
take part in more polls about what may
be covered
the future come back next week when we
get down to business and take a look at
the top 5 best Denzel Washington
performances see you then
[Music]
[Applause]
he's evolving my god it's evolving into
what come on come on within you
ah
[Music]
mommy was what my secret was mild just
like that you know and innocent Chinese
and for is more these friends even that
Bob another body cream